[Music]
there have now been more than four
million coronavirus cases in the u.s and
the pandemic has claimed more than 144
000 lives here including parents
siblings
friends teachers business owners and
frontline workers
as the country continues to face a surge
in new cases
we're sharing the stories of the
remarkable people we've lost
here are just some of the many lives to
remember
jack turnbull was a highly regarded
acting coach
and teacher in los angeles remember
acting as a muscle you have to work it
out
he saw more than 100 clients find
success in tv
and film er remember do your warm-ups as
a pirate
on actor's site a business he founded
turnbull rooted his students on with a
goofy enthusiasm
said kimberly crandall an actress and
fellow teacher
he made everybody feel their worth
[Music]
turnbull was raising three kids with his
wife jessa
we met in the philippines in 2009.
i felt like i found my mr right guy
jessa said
and that's why i fell in love with him
so quick he was so special to everyone
and to me jack turnbull was 72.
mary j wilson was the first
african-american senior zookeeper
at the maryland zoo in baltimore she
started working at the zoo in 1961
with only a high school diploma and a
love for animals
she was just an extraordinarily brave
woman said her daughter sharon wilson
jackson
and a no-nonsense lady mary would walk
through blizzards to get to work
fearlessly face loose animals even catch
escaped monkeys out of midair she spent
her entire career
in the zoo's mammal house caring for the
gorillas
elephants and big cats before retiring
in 1999
mary j wilson was 83.
[Music]
saul moreno owned a mexican restaurant
that became a mainstay
in chicago's rogers park neighborhood
he remembered every face that came
through the door
said his daughter daisy he loved his
customers
as friends moreno came to the u.s from
mexico city at 13
and would later land a job at a seafood
restaurant
with his wife maria helping in the
kitchen
he opened his own place restaurant
cuetzala
in 2005 and spent nearly every day
cooking and greeting guests his success
would help send all three kids to
college
the family plans to keep the restaurant
open daisy said
as a tribute to him sol moreno was
58.
valentina blackhorse worked as a
government administrator
for the navajo nation and dreamed of
leading her people one day
as navajo president a former pageant
queen
she was proud of her native american
heritage
the reservation which sprawls across
three southwestern states
was hit hard by the coronavirus with one
of the country's highest
infection rates when valentina's
boyfriend
got the virus she left their daughter
poet
at her grandparents while she cared for
him
then she got sick herself she gave
so much and never asked anything in
return
said her sister vanielle she was a giver
valentina blackhorse was 28.
leslie lamar parker was a tech support
specialist for a minneapolis school
district
but he dreamed of being a published
writer
it was the last wish on his bucket list
said his wife whitney
they dated long distance in college
married in 2012
and were raising two kids his spirit was
beautiful
his soul was kind he just loved
whitney said when the pandemic hit
he wrote an essay about how it brought
his family
closer i won't recall how unforgiving
the virus was to people like me
i won't talk about how scared i was for
my wife
who has severe asthma parker wrote
instead
i'll remember the conversations we had
during our sunday dinner
shortly after his death parker's essay
was published
by the food journalism site the counter
my husband gets to cross off that final
bucket list item
whitney wrote i am so grateful
my heart is so full leslie lamarr
parker was 31. boy anthony we haven't
done one of these pieces in a while i
was really
glad that we that we weren't doing them
but then when you bring them back it's
just another reminder
yes of how these people are deeply loved
and deeply missed and you look at the
ages and the different backgrounds
this virus does not discriminate and
this toll will continue to rise
a real people behind all these numbers
that we talk about every day
yeah the best way i can describe it gail
is that these are my favorite pieces
that i wish we didn't have to do because
i wish we were beyond this at this point
yes but we're not and so the best we can
do is remember and no one does it like
anthony mason well we're gonna
we as as we've been saying in it all
this week that
we're gonna have rising numbers through
the summer so unfortunately
we're gonna have to keep telling this
story